in the war in ukraine president
zielinski is vowing to retake areas
captured by russia he says long-range
weapons from the west like the u.s
high mars rather rocket system seen here
on a nighttime mission will help ukraine
win back lost ground but russia is
continuing to bombard civilian areas
deep inside ukrainian territory holly
williams has the story of one recent
victim of a russian missile strike
vera maksimenko was a retired school
teacher killed in her own home by an
airstrike on saturday
she made her final journey through the
sleepy town of sirhivka where she lived
a peaceful life until it was
extinguished ukraine says by a
soviet-era missile designed to destroy
warships
mothers of russia said this woman why do
you send your sons to kill our people
the ukrainian military told us they're
investigating the strike as a war crime
friends and family are struggling to
understand why this old lady and this
small town would be targets for vladimir
putin's
for
army
years she worked as a teacher the kids
loved her said her friend evil people
came to our country and brutally killed
her
because russia is a terrorist state but
her son dimitri told us he doesn't want
more violence or revenge i don't
need killing i want justice for your
mother
for cbs morning's holly williams
survivka ukraine